[APPLAUSE]
LARS BAK: All right.
Good morning everybody.
KASPER LUND: Morning.
LARS BAK: Thanks for coming.
It's super exciting.
We've been working on this
project for a long time,
and it's nice to see that people
are still interested in it.
It's going to be
a great two days.
There are a lot of
Dart team members.
Actually I would like to start,
ask the Dart team members
to stand up so we can see them.
And you can see
there's a lot of them.
So if you have
questions about Dart
or really want to
corner them, those
are the faces you
want to attack later.
So my name is Lars Bak, and this
is my colleague, Kasper Lund,
and we are both
engineers at Google
and have been working
on Dart for a while.
Welcome everybody.
The main purpose of this
event is to do networking.
So that means that
whenever we have breaks,
you should go and talk to people
you don't know and ask them
about how they use Dart and
listen to their success stories
and so on.
We'll try our best to get
around, talk to all of you,
and but foremost it has
to be a great event.
So I hope you will enjoy it.
We started the Dart project
four and a half years ago
to make sure that you could
be better, productive when
doing programming.
You probably all know that we
had a background in V8 doing
JavaScript, and we
thought we could
do something that was better.
In particular we wanted to
create a programming platform
where you had fast
turnaround cycles no matter
how big your program was, fast
and predictable performance.
And I think that's super
important so that the program
can understand what's going on.
The most annoying
part is you change
one small part of your
program, and suddenly it's slow
and you don't know why,
and you have to profile it.
So that was the
sign to make sure
that it was fast and predictable
no matter what kind of platform
it was running on.
Also clear language
semantics, we have a spec now.
And so you should be able
to easily figure out what's
going on when you execute Dart.
And then, lastly, we also put
in an optional strong type
system, static type system,
that's great for tooling.
So if you have a big
program and you add types,
we have tooling support for
doing refactoring and so on.
So all in all, we hope
that Dart is still
contributing to improved
programmer productivity.
So there's been a lot
of questions about Dart.
How can we improve the
Dart SDK over time?
How or where is the
robust Dart web framework?
As you all know on the web,
everything is in transition
all the time.
And sometimes you see a
framework that's coming up
and is super popular but six
months down the line, it's gone
and there's a new
one coming along.
And so that's
certainly a challenge,
and we'll talk about
that later, how
to find the robust
Dart web framework.
When can I use Dart for mobile?
So far we have mostly focused
on the web for desktops
and also for servers,
but we'll come up
with answers, how to use
Dart on mobile in this talk.
How about isolates?
Isolates have been
around for a long time.
It's the cool
talking frog in Dart,
but nobody's really using
them mostly because we
first targeted the web
platform where it's really
hard to have concurrency.
We'll be talking about
some use development
that makes isolates easy to
use and also can demonstrate
they're fairly scalable.
At the end of the talk, I
will have some milestones
for the project so you can
see what we are working on,
and so you can
sort of aim at when
you will get new features
in the Dart platform.
These are some of the
questions that we have heard,
and we will try to address
some of them in this talk,
and all else will be addressed
in the talk over the next two
days.
First, I want to talk about how
we can improve the Dart SDK.
Over the last year, we have been
moving the Dart analysis server
from within Eclipse
two an independent Dart
service that all IDs can use.
And we'll talk about later today
that we'll be using WebStorm
instead of the Dart editor.
So when we ship 1.11
and in a short while,
we will be focusing
on using WebStorm.
And that will be
a plug-in, which
is the Dart analysis server,
that will provide all
of the analysis into the ID.
And the cool thing
about this architecture
is, of course, that if you
have your own third party ID
and you want to have
a plug-in for Dart,
you basically do that by just
customizing your code to talk
to this analysis server.
We want to have
better debugging.
You probably all read about our
1.9 feature, async 0.8 which
is really, really
cool when you do
server side program in
[INAUDIBLE] and stuff
like that.
However, the problem is
when you use async 0.8,
the stack is gone.
And it's really hard to debug,
figure out what's going on.
We will in the new
version of the SDK
provide better
stack trace support
so you can see how these
state machines were created
and when they got created.
We will also focus on
interactive programming
so that when you have
a Dart program running,
you can shoot off expressions
to the running system
so you have a better interaction
with the running program that
will allow you to be more
productive when you debug.
Lastly, we are also
improving the tools.
You all know if you're
running on Windows,
that there are a lot of
symlinks when you do packages.
They are disappearing,
which is good,
which will make the
platform more robust.
We will also have
a solution that
will allow you to
bundle resources,
like picture and audio,
with the deployed Dart app.
So this should
just make it easier
for you to use Dart if
you want to do deployment.
Another focus we
have in the Dart team
is Dart for the entire web.
We want to make it is as
excellent to develop in Chrome
as it is in other browsers
or the other way around.
So right now we have
the Dartium build
of Chromium that allows you
to do fast turnaround cycles.
That works well if
you're trying it
out on Chrome, but on
other browsers like Safari
and Firefox, we would
also like to have
the same fast turnaround cycles.
So if you start a new
project called the DDC,
Dart Development Compiler.
We will allow you to
have fast turnaround
times even though
you are debugging
on any of these browsers.
So there will be a session
later today at 2:30,
where you will hear
about this new compiler.
And lastly, we also want to do
better typescript JavaScript
integration.
So if you want to use Dart for
only a part of your program,
you can do that.
Now we will talk a few words
about the web application
framework.
You probably all heard
about Angular 2.0.
This is the next generation
Angular platform.
And we will be using that as
a preferred web application
framework for Dart
moving forward.
It's not done yet, and it'll
come out later this year.
But what we already know is that
it's not as dynamic as Angular
1.0 that allows us to generate
much smaller JavaScript code
from the Dart [INAUDIBLE]
compiler, and, even better,
the resulting application
is much faster.
So, for instance,
if you have a table
and you are scrolling and
so on, the Angular 2.0
is already now
three times faster
than the previous version.
So it's looking
pretty good, and we'll
do what we can to make
it as stable as possible,
as fast as possible.
Here's the industry transition.
The whole thing is
moving from desktops
to more mobile platforms.
So we will have a
few slides presented
by Kasper talking
about how we will
attack the mobile platform.
KASPER LUND: As you're
probably aware of this,
but there's a very strong
trend in the industry
that people are moving towards--
mobile, smartphones, tablets.
People really want to run
applications in that setting
and run them really well.
And that gives us a lot of
great opportunities in the Dart
space, and I'm going
to try to tell you
a little bit about what
we're doing in that space.
So mobile I think is really an
exciting opportunity for Dart.
Dart, as a language, is really
designed for speed and size.
And that seems to fit really
well in a mobile setting.
Also, we have a strong focus
on developer productivity,
and that seems like a welcome
addition to that space.
Like a lot of the
native tool chains
that people are using
today have very long sort
of edit compile run cycles.
Which is-- I mean if you're used
to working with something Dart
and Dartium, it's very painful
to go to the native side
and experience these
minute-long pauses,
and then upload your app, run
it again, start from scratch.
It's really not a
nice experience.
And I think we can really
do even better there.
So I think mobile
is pretty exciting.
So we've been trying to
ask the question of why
do people actually want
to use Dart on mobile?
And clearly there's a desire
to use a modern and productive
technology stack on mobile.
But maybe, more
importantly, people
feel like there could be a great
story in enabling code sharing
across server and multiple
versions of the same client
apps, perhaps.
So if you're writing apps
that target iOS and Android,
you probably want to be
able to share code between.
And I think that's a space where
Dart can fit in really well.
So if you look at a
diagram like this,
imagine you have a
big application on iOS
and you have the same sort
of application on Android,
on iOS it's probably written
in Objective-C or some variant
thereof.
On Android it might
be written in Java.
And if you have the
same thing on the web
as well, you've probably written
that in this forum, probably
in Dart, and other
forums, maybe you've
written that in JavaScript.
So you're running across
these different platforms.
And you really want to be able
to have something at the bottom
here where you can
share services,
for lack of better
word, written in Dart.
And it's a bit unclear
how much of your code
you can push down there and
get the sharing benefits from.
So it might be that the
diagram is a little bit off,
that you can actually have a
lot more stuff in the Services
section given the right kind
of application architecture.
But the core notion is that
you can get this sharing.
You can write the stuff
in Dart and you can
work with that as Dart code.
We actually prototyped this.
We built a way of writing
a Dart application,
write all the business
logic or the model,
you could say, in Dart code.
And then theme it and give it
a native UI on top of that.
Here you see on
the far left, you
see an Android UI using
native Android widgets.
It's built basically
showing a list of to do.
It's a very simple
thing, but the to-dos
are implemented in Dart code.
And that model is then shown or
presented on the Android system
as a list of native widgets.
On the right side you
have the same code on iOS.
It's a slightly
different look and feel
but still a native
look and feel.
And in the middle, we
have our own command line
based UI, you could say, for
the same kind of application,
just showcasing that
you can actually
build any kind of UI you want
to for this kind of application.
It's a simple
example, but it does
show you can build native
applications in Dart code.
And we have this running
today, and I'm really
happy to get some
feedback on that
and have conversations
about that later on.
You might have a
small question here,
how do we actually run
this Dart code on iOS?
And that's something we've been
working on for a little while,
trying to make it possible
for us to run Dart well
in an iOS context.
On iOS there are
different restrictions
that make it harder for
us to run Dart code.
The Dart VM is very
much based on just
in time compilation, which
is disallowed by iOS.
So we cannot just take that as
it is and move it over there.
So we need something else
that will make our Dart code
fly on iOS.
That thing is a
runtime system for iOS,
called Fletch, which
is a small system.
It's using interpretation
based on byte codes
to fit in well in
the iOS setting.
And it's really small.
So that means that if you
have a native app for iOS,
and you want to add some
amount of Dart code to it,
adding the first line of
Dart code to your application
is not going to blow the
binary size budget you have.
So we've kept it
small and simple,
and it's basically just to
make sure we can actually
start sharing code between
Android and iOS versions
through this Dart system.
But there is a nice thing
about having a real runtime
system on these
devices, and that thing
is that you can actually do
on the fly program changes
and support that in
the runtime system.
So that means that for the
parts of your application,
for this native application
that you've written in Dart,
you can start changing that
while the program is still
executing.
And you can apply these
changes in an atomic way,
like build up a
small set of changes
that you want to fire off over
a wire protocol on a real device
running your app.
Without restarting it, you
can change the code there.
And that really enables
fast development workflows,
and it actually might be
a way of enticing people
to write more of their
stuff in Dart because they
get the benefit
without having to go
through an expensive edit,
compile, restart cycle.
There's a session about this
is called Dart for Mobile
tomorrow at 4:30, and we'll
go into a lot more details
about what this and
how this actually
feels like from a
developer's perspective.
There is another
area that I'm sort of
touched on that also feels ripe
for improvements, Isolates.
So when we shipped the
first version of Dart,
people got really
excited about isolates.
It seems like everybody,
at least almost everybody
likes the idea of
isolates, like the ability
to scale and get parallelism
into your code, security
and plugins and actually
having a way of running code
in a sandbox setting,
and maybe my favorite
is the ability to actually
enforce resource constraints.
At least in theory,
you can take an isolate
and say, I only want to give
you two megabytes of memory
to run your stuff.
And if you cannot live within
that, I can shut you down.
It feels like a
really strong thing
because the isolates
are so disconnected.
In practice, however, we
found that almost nobody
likes to use them.
Like they are powerful
and you can use them,
but they are hard to use
and they really-- They
have a sort of
cumbersome feel to them,
and, maybe the worst
thing, is that it
seems like simple things
are a little bit hard to do.
And that's a really
bad place to be.
Some people have built really
fantastic things with isolates,
but I think it's more in
spite of the current APIs
than it's because of them.
They are actually hard to use.
So to give you an idea of
where we'd like to take this,
I'm going to give you a
small example of what another
isolate API might look like and
how we could improve things.
Fractals.
This is probably not the
most beautiful rendering
of a Mandelbrot fractal
that you've seen.
If it is then, you have
some online searching to do.
But this is fairly simple.
But it is a problem.
Like computing this
thing is a problem
that's easy to [? paralyze, ?]
just not very easy
in Dart today.
So how do we make this easy
to [? paralyze ?] in Dart?
Well, the way to actually
compute something like this,
could look a little
bit like this.
Right.
You have a way of rendering
the entire fractal
and getting a list of the
strings out you want to print.
Every single line needs to be
rendered to a string as well.
And every single character
rendered in the line
needs to be rendered
to a character.
If you look at the first
render fractal line
up there, one way of
doing it is saying,
I want to get a list
out with all the strings
that come out of actually
calling render line.
So I can generate a list
and fill in the contents
from calling render line
sort of in sequence.
This is actually fairly
simple code in many ways,
and hopefully, given
a little bit of time,
you could also just like
start hacking on this
and making it better.
So there are like 24,000
entries in this diagram.
It would be nice if
you could compute
them a little bit faster.
So imagine the motherboard
execution on there
is expensive.
You want to [? paralyze ?] that.
How would you do that?
Well, if you consider
adding a little bit of space
for putting in the
parallel constructs here,
and you just go ahead and say,
I want to run this kind of thing
in parallel.
So what do I need to
add to make this happen?
Well, first of all,
you need to have
some construct for running a
list of actions in parallel.
So I turned the render line
called in to a closure,
that actually will
be an action for me
that I can call
later on, and then
I just tell the system I want
to run these in parallel.
That seems like a pretty simple,
straightforward transition
from a simple serial
API to a parallel one.
It relies on us being able to
block at this point and say,
I cannot really continue running
the render fractal method until
I get a reply back.
So it puts pressure on us
to deliver something that's
synchronous because
that's the only way you
can go in a trivial away from
a serial or simple to parallel.
You can take this
to another level
by doing the same thing
at the render line thing.
Once you do this, then
you get actually something
like more than
24,000 independent
isolates that sort
of communicate
and get a reply back.
So if you want to make this
happen and to make it fast,
you need to be able to sort
of lots and lots of isolates
running concurrently.
The nice thing is that we
actually built this and we
prototyped this on top of Fletch
that has really lightweight
isolates and a way of doing
more synchronous API's.
And maybe the
final thing to note
here is that it also supports
sending closures like this
from one isolate to another.
As long as the things you're
sending are immutable,
you can send them without
copying them over,
and that makes it really
to express these things.
It's a way of rethinking
the core isolate
APIs to make things like
parallelism a lot easier.
So on my 16 core machine at the
office, I get these results.
Instead of doing it just
as a set of serial steps,
you can run them in parallel
this, 24,000 plus isolates.
And that's 15.5
performance increase, which
fits pretty well with the
scalability constraints
we have here.
I mean, it's a
simple system, but it
shows that just fanning and
generating lots of isolates
and then sort of reducing that,
to a simple, in this case,
list of strings works
pretty well already.
And it's a different way
of thinking about isolates
and what we can do.
It is research directions.
We're trying to figure
out if this is enough,
and I think it's pretty
clear that it's not enough.
But it's a good place
to start to get--
to make it much, much
easier to actually build
parallel stuff in Dart.
It's based on
synchronous operations.
It's based on this notion
of not copying things
when you pass messages.
When they are
immutable, you can just
block your current isolate, fan
out, and hand over reference
to these mutable
data because it's
safe to do so if
they are mutable.
And it's also based on
really lightweight isolates.
So I think that that's sort
of the core of what we're
trying to do with isolates,
make it a lot easier to use
and also make it a
lot more powerful.
[APPLAUSE]
LARS BAK: So many of you
probably ask questions.
So we have Fletch and
we have the Dart VM.
Are they sort of spitting it?
So the way you
should think about
is the Fletch VM right now
is sort of mostly a research
vehicle.
It's not done yet.
And many of the
ideas with isolates
can easily be transferred
to the Dart VM.
So if these features
pan out, they
will be available for
all Dart execution.
KASPER LUND: Yes, it's mostly
about getting the feature set
right, and I think
you play a big part
in helping us determine
what's right before starting.
LARS BAK: Yes.
Yes.
KASPER LUND: This direction now.
LARS BAK: Learning
a new language,
learning a new
platform takes a while.
And this slide here is to tell
you to tell about Dart is here
for the long run.
We've been doing
Dart exclusively
for four and a half years
and we'll continue to do so.
Many projects inside Google
have invested a lot in Dart,
and they will continue to do so.
Also on the outside, and
you will hear many talks
during these two days
about how external projects
and companies are using Dart.
I'll just let you read you the
part of this quote from Scott
Silver, the VP of Engineering
for Ads, who has decided
to build the next key-- the next
generation of platform based
on Dart.
So Dart will be here
for the long run.
And it's important
for you guys to know
because if you have to bet
on Dart for your company,
it's good to know
that it will be around
for the next many years.
Here is the best roadmap
I could come up with.
It's an animated slide so
it will be more (laughing).
In May we will
migrate to Github,
consolidate our source code.
In 1.11 we will
retire the Dart ID
and provide a
plug-in for WebStorm.
So from then on, WebStorm
is the ID for Dart.
We'll be adding HTTP
2 and Google RPC
in 1.12, which is nice.
We will give you
Fletch, the new VM.
That will be a
beta version in Q3.
And the final version
will come out in Q4.
And the fact that we can run
Dart code without generating
code will be great for iOS so
we can ship mobile applications
on that platform.
We will also provide
the Dart mobile services
so we have a way of-- You could
take your Dart business logic
and hook up to native UI digits.
And we'll provide generators
that are based on IDL.
They will generate all
the wire protocol for you.
And then in the beginning
of the next year,
it'll be Dart SDK 2.0.
But don't worry, it'll be
mostly backwards compatible.
This is not Python.
[LAUGHTER]
What we will do, however,
is we will guarantee
that the programming
language is backwards
compatible completely.
If we do incompatible
changes in Dart SDK 2.0,
we'll make sure
there is a migration
tool that will
automatically convert
your code to the new version.
And you can ask, why
are we doing all this?
Well, there are some
parts of the core Dart SDK
we would like to
get out in packages,
for instance like HTML,
and so we can faster
rev that and so on.
But trust us, we
will do whatever
we can to make sure that
it's an easy transition.
The Dart dev compiler you
will hear about later today
will also be part
of the SDK 2.0.
So this is very exciting,
but what you can hopefully
see-- I'll cross the
line here-- We'll
do what we can to make the Dart
SDK more robust, easier to use,
and at the same time adding some
interesting features for mobile
and the web.
So with that in mind,
I'll say thank you.
And I hope you have
a great two days.
Do we have time for
questions or not?
We do not have
time for questions.
But that-- this is great.
But--
KASPER LUND: There's a panel
tomorrow, tomorrow yeah.
LARS BAK: There's plenty
of time for discussion
and just please approach
me if you have questions.
But you can also
add your questions
to the Dart summit
questions-- Dory page.
And there'll be a
panel where we can
answer all the hard questions.
So, welcome to the show.
And I will leave it up
for the next speaker.
KASPER LUND: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]